these are horrible did I skip this one
that's insane
like somebody's sticking like anything
up here we throw absolutely not it
started just the way you handed it off
to me is like already make any marriage
a lady came in with a knife still in her
vagina she claimed that an intruder
assaulted her but the area was not
bleeding It was as if the knife was slid
into her she later revealed that she did
it to herself to get revenge on her
boyfriend I need to reread this like
this doesn't make sense this selected
this is so dumb I don't understand how
like that's revenge on someone else I
really want to know what kind of revenge
she's getting on her boyfriend what did
he do to this poor woman I'm gonna show
this to my boyfriend so that anytime he
tells me I'm crazy I'm gonna be like not
this crazy though that's the first one a
patient who decided to stick a crochet
needle up his penis wild drunk the
urologist on call had to surgically
remove the object hopefully he was
blackout and couldn't feel anything why
are they always drunk I think they're
not really drunk I think they're just
pretending they're drunk I also wonder
what the process is to surgically remove
something from the inside of a penis
every time I picture somebody cutting
open a penis or surgically remove it I
just picture like it going like a flower
a guy put a light blub a guy put a light
bulb up his butt I asked him how they
got it out and the response was with
great difficulty
a light bulb is like the most fragile
thing where does the light bulb crack if
it was the back end of the life of that
you screw in then maybe he was doing
some like I have moment I thing like but
like AHA but moment a
came in with penis issues there's a lot
of like a penis issues yeah turned out
he shoved a piece of floss really far up
his urethra just so he could get out of
his cell okay I get it
I mean like want to get out but like
holy crap oh I don't even know how you
get a piece of floss up your urethra
like did he have some sort of toothpick
I'm really curious how his people I do
it you I do I respect that was a patient
came to the ER because he had a cucumber
stuck in his rectum before he decided to
come in he tried to get it out with a
knife the doctor came out of the room
with a very large bloody cucumber he
tried to get it out with a knife just
know what that is abusive vegetables
that is vegetable abuse this guy had a
lot of other options besides sticking a
knife up his rectum to receive this
cucumber he probably could have got like
a if we're in a kitchen already cuz
clearly he's in the kitchen you got a
cucumber up there you got a knife I'm
thinking go for some tongs one day a
woman came waddling in with a set of
tongs stuck between her legs this is
what that guy should have used to get
that cucumber out of his rectum she used
them to masturbate and inserted the
tongs into her vagina I feel you the
clip that holds the town was shut opened
and the times became hopelessly lodged
into her vagina she had to be taken to
the operating room to have them
surgically removed and nearly perforated
her uterus oh gosh oh that's really bad
I mean I get it you just start using
stuff at times but like holy bananas
this is not okay the pain this woman
must have been in just because she was
trying to rub one off is insane I mean I
don't think I'm ever gonna look at
kitchen dogs the same way ever again a
man came into the ER blue in the face
looking like he was about to die they
checked all over his body but couldn't
forgot what was wrong they flipped him
over and saw a tail coming out of his
butthole after doing a CT scan they
found a rat inside his rectum oh my god
the rat bit the rat bit off part of his
colon and the man was suffering from
internal
leading which is wise face turn blue
apparently the man decided to place a
condom over the live rat to suffocate it
and then place it up his butt
so it's breathing what hit its prostate
and he would feel pleasure the man made
a full recovery but the poor rat died I
don't even know what the thing this is a
ride this was a ride to read I feel bad
for that right the intricacy of like the
breathing of a rat I'm gonna put the
condom there and I'm gonna put it on my
prostate and that's gonna feel something
like I feel like shouldn't we just
invent a sex toy that can like mimic
this rather than sticking live rats up
her ass idiot
what an idiot how did he even wrestle it
up his butt in the first place
everything before this was like nothing
compared to this okay this is the worst
one this is the next level I'm pretty
sure this is gonna be the worst one in
here and if it's not I am in for a treat
and a woman would put Campbell's beef
soup in her vagina because her boyfriend
liked to eat it from there we had to
fish out a potato that was lodged in
there oh my god this woman definitely
have some sort of like yeast infection
like you can't put you can't put beef
soup that's so good I'm so grossed out
by that I do like the fact that it was
Campbell's soup that's classic though
that's classic it's hearty [ __ ] also
how do you figure out that that's what
you like to do like where is that
connected to in your life that you're
like you know what the beef soup would
be great out of a badge last wine the
craziest thing was Vivian came in with a
Barbie dolls arm stuck in his urethra
apparently he ordered a sex doll off
eBay and when it arrived it was actually
a Barbie doll he was so angry that he
ripped off the dolls arm and shoved it
up his penis I didn't know like so many
things can go up a penis so things they
in places that don't belong there
I get it like you order you wanted a sex
now you got a Barbie doll I'll be pissed
too because you probably were expecting
to have the time
you're in life but when you got piss you
probably should have just sent them back
instead of sending it up your penis some
of us would maybe try eBay support like
if anything were to be shoved up
anywhere like Barbie doll up but like
that would be probably the most normal
story that I have read today so far I
feel that people would need another way
to release their sexual frustrations
because that's what I got from the
morally it's a lot of sexual frustration
I feel like most people are dumb and
that I am very glad that I'm not a
doctor or nurse because I don't know how
I would react to these things in person
I really want to know how often stories
like these happen like if this is a
nurses daily thing or if it's just like
a once in a blue moon I feel like these
are unfortunately common things don't
try this at home
that freaking rat one really is is
something like